عروض بالدبابات الغربيه انهمرت على
القياده الاوكرانيه خلال الايام الماضيه
من فرنسا والولايات المتحده والماضيه
دبابات وصفت بالخفيفه اثار التساؤلات حول
مدى تاثيرها بالحرب الدائره في اوكرانيا
وان كانت ستصب بخانه زياده العقبات
اللوجستيه خبراء عسكريون اكدوا انما وعدت
به وبتقديمه البلدان الثلاثه اي اي ام اكس
دبابات على الاطلاق بل المركبات قتاليه
مدرعه اصغر واخف واسرع حركه من ذبابات
القتال الرئيسيه ومزوده بمدفع عن رئيسيه
بعيار اصغر من اي دبابه عاديه واقل تدري
عنها الميزه الرئيسيه للدبابات الخفيفه هي
استخدامها بمختلف الادوار بما فيها نقل
القوات واسناد المشات والدعم في الحرب ضد
الدروع والاستطلاع طبعا هذه المركبات
مشاهدينا قادره قلب موازين القوى وفق
خبراء تكتيكيا ستوفر قدره اكبر على تحرك
والسرعه والحمايه في دعم عمليات المشاه
كما انها اسرع استجابه في المواقف
المتغيره اي التكيف مع طبيعه الاراضي او
الاحوال الجويه ولديها امكانيات اطلاق
النار عن بعد ما يتيح هزيمه الدبابات
الروسيه بالصواريخ المضاده للدبابات اما
على المستوى العملات فاثبت الجيش
الاوكراني انه ينفذ عمليات الاسلحه
المشتركه بكفاءه غير ان هذه الانظمه
ستحتاج طبعا الى اسابيع من التدريب على
تشغيلها وصيانتها وقد تحتاج لتعديلات
وبالتالي انشاء مسار لوجستي لتوفير قطع
الغيار والاصلاحات كما ستتسبب بتحديات
لوجيسيه كبيره قد تترافق مع احتماليه
التصعيد الصراع وتوسيعه بين روسيا والغرب